let me also first
welcome all the participants and a very
good evening to all so so next what we
have is a detailed description of the
program so I will start with the
objectives of this program so our
program aims to cultivate an
understanding of multiomics studies
Technologies and state-of-the-art
computational methods for analysis of
omits data sets
so our objective is to provide The
Cutting Edge skill sets to efficiently
plan for multi-omics experiments and
generate the different layers of
biological data and the participants our
objective is to make them efficiently
analyze and interpret the outcomes of
their experiments with the kind of
training skill set that we will provide
through this program
so our program modules are basically
divided into three uh groups we can say
so uh first module is about omics
experiments and the technologies that
are available in the market so in that
we provide uh basic understanding of how
you can plan your experiments how you
can perform omic studies designs and how
you can use an externalization
sequencing Technologies uh including
microarrays and SNB typing Etc and also
state of the art single cell and spatial
transcriptomics uh in second module we
have
focus on omics data science so uh there
in the basic we will cover in the
certificate one the basics of the
analysis and including the state of the
art methods for the NGS data analysis
what are different types of omics data
types that are available uh in the open
databases Etc and uh we will also have
data science methods to be taught for
omics data sets we will also focus on AI
and ml applications in omics how you one
can utilize available uh tools in the AI
and ml domain for analyzing the omics
data sets and finally in the third
domain we focus on omics applications
where the modern approaches for drug
designing and precision medicine as well
as drug Target and Drug Discovery and
special Focus also on on applications in
the clinical domain
so this is an overview of the modules
that will be covered in certificate 1
certificate two and uh that we are
planning to offer so uh so the program
structure if we look at more
specifically what kind of courses that
will be scattered in this certificate
programs so certificate one as Professor
mitali mentioned it will be catering to
the basic training so there we will have
uh courses on design of on weeks
experiments so it will cover how you can
design your Comics experiments what are
different technicalities and the
concepts behind designing and of omics
experiment then we have a basic course
also on the end Next Generation omics
technology so what are the
state-of-the-art technologies that they
will be introduced and also basics of
data analytics methods will be exposed
to uh to the participants
including the state-of-the-art comics
databases which are available in the
public domain they will be introduced to
the participants and then participants
will have option to choose electives
from the available elective booklet that
I will be displaying in the next slide
so you can see that uh we have this
credit structure the three credit uh or
two zero two that means you will have a
lab also in this course
um so uh these are some four compulsory
courses that you have to take in the
certificate one and including one
elective so in total uh you are expected
to complete 13 credits to obtain
certificate one similarly in certificate
2 which is more of an advanced version
of certificate one so it will be more
advanced in terms of both Technologies
analysis as well as cover different
specific applications so these are the
different courses that will be taught in
certificate 2 and most importantly you
will have the mini project which also I
am going to talk and there is one
special slide for mini project
um and then again you will have the
option to choose electives
so certificate 2 has a lot of more of
hands-on experience as well as you can
see that there are a lot of 202 courses
here uh including my electives so
um yeah so starting with two in total
you have to earn 15 credits so uh these
are the options that will be available
for elective courses as you can see that
for certificate one we have six elective
courses uh catering to different uh
domains like the technology analysis and
also uh applications a little bit of
applications in the drug Discovery and
other domains and certificate two which
is more advanced as I say so you will
have more of Hands-On sessions so uh all
of the electives that you see here is uh
offered in a 202 mode that is mostly you
will have a lot of Hands-On training
um
and also we are covering different uh
sectors like AIML and computational
applications and plant Science and omic
Space Precision medicine
Etc so these are all broadly covering
most of the domains that that nowadays
applicable to so uh in the next slide we
have the student Journey so how your
journey will be throughout this program
so uh there are different uh options to
enter the program so so for example uh
you first we will start with application
submission and uh you can enter at
certificate one and if you just want to
you know um get trained with a very
basic on a skills in this domain so you
can exit uh by at with your certificate
one uh completing the 13 credits
there is another also an option that you
if you already have exposure to the
courses or the the content that is
covered in certificate one you can even
enter at certificate two it's directly
and still there is a possibility to
obtain the PG diploma so for that you
have to uh two options either you exit
with your certificate too so you
complete 15 credits and then you exit or
you additionally are 13 credits from the
specified electric courses so that in
total you earn 15 plus 13 that is 28
credits and then you can also obtain a
PG diploma so uh there are multiple
options that are available so depending
on your need
yeah and also most importantly there
will be a short placement support for
the top performance uh in this uh PG
diploma course
so uh
regarding the eligibility so uh these
are minimum eligibility that each one
has to satisfy in order to get enroll in
this successfully enroll in this program
so you need to have either a bachelor's
degree in engineering or science or
medicine uh which is
a minimum four years program or one can
also be a master's degree in
bioengineering or by science or in a
related field
and a minimum of 60 marks in a ugpg
level is required and or a minimum of
cgpa in case your grading is on cgpa 6.0
uh on a scale of 10 or corresponding
proportional requirements when the
scales are other than 10. we will be
giving a preference uh to working
professionals because this program is
mainly meant for what to do skill
working professionals that are in
industry or r d Laboratories or academic
institutions
so this is barely the minimum
eligibility that one has to uh
one has to hold and uh there will be a
little bit of more selection criteria
and that we will be talking about later
in the FAQ session
so in addition to eligibility there are
some prerequisites also so for
certificate one because this is very
basic uh level of training so uh there
is no assets prerequisites but for
certificate two if you are entering
directly a certificate 2 then
uh it is expected that you should have
completed 13 credits of coursework or
equivalent in the topics that are
covered in certificate one so these are
the topics as I also shown in the last
two slides that you have to have some
understanding of experiment design uh
multiomics resources and technology and
basics of omics data analysis for the PG
diploma there will be uh again
prerequisites if you want to earn PG
diploma there will be uh either you if
you are entering through certificate one
then there is access no PG diploma
prerequisites but if you are entering
through certificate 2 for a PG diploma
then you have to have again completed 13
credits of course work or equivalent in
the below topics
um
yeah so uh regarding the fees so uh this
is also we have put up in the brochure
and just want to again uh show you so uh
we have certificate one that is duration
is of almost six months and uh total
credits to be honest 13 and more of uh
this uh program will be online
completely certificate one and the fees
is uh 1.2 lakh and for certificate two
which is uh again six months Advanced
Training Program uh you have uh more
Hands-On and uh experience you will be
gaining so it will have 15 credits in
total it will be online so theoretical
persons will be delivered online whereas
the Hands-On and the Practical sessions
we have uh there will be an immersion so
campus immersion
so uh we will have one slide also on
campus immersion so I will discuss more
about immersion next in the next slide
um its face is uh about 1.5 lakh and uh
diploma uh is uh 12 months so you have
to earn a certificate one and
certificate two that is one option if
you enter a certificate one and if you
enter at certificate two still you have
to take 13 additional credits from the
elective that will be offered so in
total you have to complete 28 credits uh
again so it will be online as well as
the Hands-On and practical sessions will
be given during the immersion period uh
and total fees for diploma is 2.5 lakh
and there will be a campus immersion
fish of uh 10 000 rupees uh that doesn't
exclude uh accommodation uh sorry that
excludes accommodation and food so uh
that is just uh to describe the fee
structure
and then we have uh
this campus immersion I was talking
about in the last slide so uh the this
is a compulsory uh requirement for
certificate to program and as well as
for PG diploma because uh it it will you
will have to go through practical
sessions and Hands-On training uh in
physical mode so duration will be
maximum 15 days for this immersion uh it
is most likely we plan in summer so we
will be informing the exact dates uh to
selected candidates when we circulate
the academic calendar to the selected
candidates so in during this immersion
so participants as I said will engage in
dry or wet lab sessions and so that to
enable them to gain practical skills and
insights
and you will have unique opportunity to
interact with industry experts as well
as faculty members from IIT jodhpur and
you will have learning from their vast
expertise and experiences
so mini projects uh was also uh one
thing that I wanted to talk because uh I
think there was some queries also from
participants so mini project is a
planned for certificate to
um or if you are doing PC diploma so it
will help you to apply your knowledge in
the real world problems and again a
practical experience by solving the a
small project so it's a mini project of
three credit there are different options
to complete your mini project so you can
do in your project entirely with the
iitj faculty or you can do also in the
industry where you are working or other
any other industry but there has to be
some core supervisor from IIT jodhpur so
that he The Faculty from IIT jodhpur is
aware of what kind of project you are
working on
and uh there is a another option is that
you can also take uh some courses a mini
project courses to complete your three
credits so we will provide a list of uh
specified courses that can be undertaken
to complete uh your mini project
yeah so uh after going through the
program so uh you will have the ability
to understand uh different uh Next
Generation multi-ohomics Technologies
and you will have capability to design
the experiment for conducting the omic
studies and ability to apply machine
learning statistics and as well as
computational methods for basic to
Advanced analysis of different omics
data sets and you you will have the
knowledge of different NGS experiments
and their possible applications in
different sectors and you will develop
skills to interpret the analysis
outcomes for biological inference
lettering to your specific needs and
efficiently you will be able to
efficiently plan and manage technical
projects in different omics domains so
these are all attributes and that UV
expect to be a ah available to the
participants
so uh there were also some queries so
again regarding the career opportunities
after going through this program so uh
just want to show you some of the them
so there are career opportunities in
different sectors as you can see they
are highlighted data analytics companies
or diagnostic laboratories or Healthcare
organizations or research institutions
as well as in biopharma so uh
there are some of the companies that are
listed here uh to each of these sectors
so TCS by informatics Center for example
in data analytics SEC domain
then you have met genome map my genome
and a lot of diagnostic laboratories and
startups that are working in this sector
Health Care organizations like hospitals
and as well as in him aims and 40
self-care Etc and then in different
academic research institutions there is
also a need or there is a possibility to
join
um
and also in different biopharma which
are switching now to uh as well as to
NGS Technologies and genomics based uh
approaches for diagnosis and uh
development of drugs so
um these are different job roles that uh
one can
take after going through this program so
one can become bioinformatics analyst or
genomic researcher clinical research
associate or data scientist enomix
domain uh computational biologists
scientific officer and biomedical data
analyst and omics project manager so you
will have the skills to manage different
kinds of omics projects so uh these are
you can see that there is a vast scope
and there is a lot of opportunities
after completing this program
so I would like to now uh thank you for
uh listening this to talk but there will
be uh more uh things following this
presentation so let me also show you
what are the different people we have on
board so we have Rich Professor mitali
who has Decades of experience in the
genomics we have
experienced uh program mentors like Dr
Praveen and Dr Gotham thus from my biome
so uh we have also a very rich
experience program advisors like Dr
Mohit who's also partnering in offering
this program uh they are doing these
kind of skill based trainings a lot in
India and also abroad
and myself Dr pankaj and Dr sucharita
will be program directors for this
program so anything from this from your
start journey to end Journey we will be
available to help you with resolve your
all kind of queries and concerns that
you will have throughout the program so
I would like to now request Dr Mohit if
you uh because we want to also hear
about our industry Partners so Dr Mohit
if you can take over and maybe explain
about Pine bytech economics logic